okay yeah thanks for the invitation to
the workshop I don't usually talk in his
community so it's nice to meet some new
people or potentially you know I didn't
get anybody yet but yeah so this is
joint work with the Roman all down
inside Weitzman and just Affleck was a
temporary defeat and I teach on on
Wednesdays and Fridays so this is
doubling as the lecture lecture from my
class so I say hi to my class lecture 13
so to start we should we should review
what happened in your last lecture it's
a it's a joke you don't have to have
read the notes so in the talk x will be
a xt will be reversible markov chain on
a state space Omega and we'll assume it
converges to a stationary measure pie
and then L is the laplacian which for me
is going to be positive definite and at
least for the next few slides will need
the continuous-time heat semigroup okay
so he'd semi-good that gives a
continuous-time heat flow and then okay
of course we also have the corresponding
a douche life-form which gives us the
sort of local correlation between two
functions along the chain this is all
review I I hope I expected some portions
audiences seen these things before and
and then if we have this set up if we
start with an initial density H naught
so this is some initial distribution of
heat in the space and then HT is the is
the time evolution of the heat flow
starting from H naught then we have the
heat equation which tells us how the
heat flow evolves in time and it just
follows immediately from the definition
of the heat semigroup if you were but
you have to remember how matrix
multiplication works so in this setup
there's a transpose there ok so if you
set this up then you can do something
natural for everybody which is talk
about convergence equilibrium and of
course I mean how you get you know how
you convert equilibrium depends on your
notion of the distance to equilibrium
by the way I mean I review all this so
that we just to motivate the definition
of the Lok Sabha live in equality if you
know this stuff anyone has gone out for
a second but for instance if you measure
convergence in the l2 distance in terms
of the variance then the heat equation
immediately gives you the rate of decay
of the variance in terms of the dish
life form so and then if you think about
the fact that heat tends to decay
exponentially then it makes sense to
look at the logarithmic derivative okay
and so if you look at the logarithmic
derivative sort of the worst case over
overall functions you can encounter of
course that's just the spectral gap of
the chain and then you know you can
equivalently define the spectral gap is
the best constant so that so that you
get this kind of exponential decay in
the variance for every initial density
okay so this is how you you know if you
if you care about this into stationarity
in terms of the say you measure it in l2
okay then spectral gap gives you a nice
theory for the rate of exponential decay
and if you care about the distance to
stationarity in terms of a different
measure like say the relative entropy
distance to the stationary measure so
okay so so this quantity which we
represent by n PI of a density H this is
the relative entropy between the
distribution specified by by HT and the
stationary measure pie I just wrote down
the definition and you can do the same
thing you compute the derivative you see
that it's you can write in terms of the
dish life form now H and luggage you can
define the corresponding logarithmic
derivative and you get the same kind of
thing except now you you have a
exponential decay in terms of the
entropy instead of the l2 distance okay
so I mean this is a all very sort of
straightforward and if you now if you
have some bounds of course on lambda or
the row 0 this modified lok sabha live
constant then you get some quantitative
measure of conversions to stationarity
right and by the way just to stress the
advantage maybe for instance of the
locks over love is that is that in
general the entropy tends to be somewhat
smaller than the variance
so if you know if you have a uniform
distribution on n sites your variants
might be something like n squared
where's your entropy is at most log in
ok so if you have exponential decay then
you get some better say mixing time
bounced from using the modified locks /
lives all of this is very natural it
looks you know looks like it looks very
nice but there's a reason it's called
the modified Lok Sabha left constant
because they are the real locks of love
constant which is the first quantity
that looks bizarre it looks foreign so
this is the so so this was the modified
log so constant from the previous slide
and you there's a there was a motivation
for it it's just the logarithmic
derivative of the worst logarithmic
derivative of the distance of the
relative entropy to state you know
addition to stationarity so this was
well motivated this one looks strange
and in fact it like when I saw it you
know as a grad student a long time ago
it's just I thought okay one day I'll
say I'll know what this means like why
you would write this down so since it's
a little bit relevant for talk let me
let me tell you where it comes from if
you think about diffusions instead of
discrete space chains so like a Brownian
motion on our end for instance then the
deer chili form is given by the inner
product of a grad F and grad G and then
you have the integration by parts
formula which says you can write it also
in terms of the laplacian and in the
setting of diffusions where you can do
calculus if you write the gear soli form
of square root of square root of f ok so
this is just a definition and then the
next part is just ok derivative of
square root of f is 1 over 2 root f
times the derivative of f chain rule and
then you use the chain rule one more
time to write this in terms of grad log
f then you see that in the in the case
of diffusion so in space is continuous
you can by the way you can take this
equality here sort of the definition of
what a diffusion is but then those two
things are the same up to this constant
on one fourth so there's no
distinguishing between them but it
happens that in the discrete setting
there really can be different things the
basic reason is that if you combine the
heat equation with integration by parts
it gives you some very delicate sort of
a relationship between time and space
the discrete space chains just don't
have ok so when one thing you can ask by
the ways you can ask is this like maybe
this you know okay so you do this but
maybe this is just an artifact maybe
this log saw a lot of cancer constant is
not a real thing like it's just some
funny looking expression but I mean but
it is real for instance I mean I it
controls the l2 mixing time of the chain
up to up to some factor which is doubly
loggers making the minimum stationary
probability right so it is also as many
people know it's also equivalent to a
sort of hyper contractivity of the heat
flow operator in a formal sense so it's
a it's a real thing that has sort of
corresponds to real phenomena even in
discrete-time chains and then you can
relate all these things together you
know the sort of having a log so believe
in equality is stronger than having a
modified lots of 11 equality is stronger
than having a spectral gap in equality
of conquering equality with the same
with the same constants and this is the
end of the story although I did want to
say that sort of the left hand side here
is is due to a decoder stencil of cost
and one thing that would be nice for me
is if somebody could explain this proof
to me so I mean I understand the proof
but i mean like i don't i would i would
prefer a different proof because i don't
really understand the proof i could
write the proof down and i've asked this
a number of times for somebody to
explain to me so far nobody has
volunteered but today is another
opportunity i feel super comfortable
yeah I also asked Percy to explain it to
me he referred me to that to the paper I
but well one thing I yeah what's the
what's the problem are you volunteering
to explain it to me no I think I think
the fact that that you can't explain
this to me in the hallway is a failing
and understanding and one thing I would
hope is that the method I show in a few
slides in particular can give a proof of
this that doesn't involve operator
interpolation and analytic continuation
of the heat flow and so on okay but just
in this inequality there is a lot going
on that okay I don't see people explore
so much so let me tell you the point of
the talk today which is just to talk
about path couplings and lots of living
equalities so a very brief history
actually this is the point where I'm
worried to talk is being recorded with
the brief history here is that so I'll
say so we're going to talk about path
coupling so trains change the hell of
contraction that's what i mean by
curvature in this case positive
curvature this is in the setting of
diffusion so continuous space so
positive curvature for instance if you
want you can take to be a say if you're
on a manifold a uniform lower bounds on
the on the Ricci curvature but you can
also ignore all of those words so okay
so but Karina Marie gave a very nice
beautiful method for showing that
positive curvature yields quantitatively
alok so believe in equality and and then
in two thousand auto and villainy I sort
of get some alternate proofs of this and
stronger versions of this using the sort
of beautiful interpretation of the of
the diffusion as as just gradient
descent on some manifold okay so this is
a very powerful point of view that has
inspired huge amounts of work since then
which I will now not summer
and let's just say they in recent years
there's been a very large body of work
by a huge number of people with
different interests and different
motivations on I'm getting these things
to work in the setting of discrete
spaces or general metric measure spaces
for lots of different motivations from
me from optimal transport and functional
analysis and remaining in geometry and
mixing times ok so just I mean you know
I just say that you know the people
involved like a lot Villa nice term
their students Prasad you know his group
Catalan Martin I'm sure I in a neglect a
large body of work but about we don't
have this don't talk is only 45 minutes
so we we now move on let me just say the
the main problem here in developing this
theory is that they're sort of there's
two things you can do one is you can
make a strong enough definition of
positive curvature in the discrete
setting that some of the methods from
continuous space go through and then you
can you can you can sort of simulate
them or be inspired by them and do a lot
of work and get some results and then
the problem is that those definitions
don't apply obviously or don't apply at
all too many chains that you would like
to study and then there's another
approach which is you can make a
definition that's broad enough to
capture lots of chance and then you
can't prove anything about it and I
would say that okay all the approaches
fall somewhere in that spectrum okay so
let me give you some idea what we'll
talk about in the next slide so if this
is the set of things that are sort of
like interesting to people doing mixing
times and then this is the set of things
that are interesting to people doing a
you know functional analysis optimal
transport reminding geometry it would be
great to study a question which is in
the intersection of them so today
instead what will i'll just say about a
problem which is in there in the
complement of the union which is still
scientific progress because you know i
mean you know you have to know not to
look out here ok i'm just i said you'll
see in a second I like the question but
it's a one might say that that
okay it's alright let's wait okay let me
tell you the question you can decide
where the dot falls okay so now let's
just let's awed meant our state state
state space with a metric those metric
is d and then we can define this notion
of course curvature okay so we just you
put some metric on your Spade space you
still have a state spaces of a your
reversible Markov chain so the chain has
curvature at least Kappa okay so this is
in the definition given by yon Olivier
but sort of following you know an
intense amount of work on path coupling
which is the same thing so okay so
what's the requirement it's that if you
if you start your your random walk from
you or you started from V for any two
sites then it should exist a coupling of
sort of one step from you on one step of
V that on average decreases the distance
between the between the where you end up
so for every U and V there's a coupling
of the random walk of one step that
decreases the difference the distance in
expectation so that happens so if
there's a contracting coupling then you
say they of course Ricci curvature at
least Kappa okay and just some
motivation for the why it's called
course Ricci curvature why Olivier
introduced it in this way it's because I
mean if you look at a by the way now you
see my my skills with geometry so if you
look at a positively curved manifold
then it happens that if you take two
points and you take balls around each of
them then you can transport the mass of
one ball to the other using an average
amount of distance which is in general
smaller than the distance between the
midpoints so sort of the balls are
closer together than their mid points on
average if you're in a even of you if
you're in a flat space like the like of
the line then you know then the average
is viewing the balls is just exactly the
same as a distance between the midpoints
and if you were in a negatively curved
space like this piece of the tree then
it then the sort of that on average the
balls around these two points are
actually further away than the midpoints
because you have must learn more mass
going this way then you have going
towards the two points so this is why I
mean this is the pictorial version why
call this curvature and in fact it also
corresponds to I mean if you look at
just diffusions on manifolds then sort
of this definition captures a lower
bound on reaching curvature there ok so
that's the that's the definition what's
the question we were going to talk about
so it's a very nice conjecture of you
ballin per Sode a which basically says
that whenever you have a coupling it's
contracting whenever you have course
reaching curvature at least Kappa then
you also have a log so blur in equality
or modified Lok Sabha living equality
and under sort of a the most sloppy sort
of metric cessation of the chain so
whenever there's a nonzero chance to
jump from X to Y in discrete time you
you put distance one there and then you
just take the induced metric so you just
put it you know it's just the graph
metric you put an edge whenever you
could make a jump and then you take the
induced metric take that metric D you
could as if it has non-trivial curvature
than the claim is that the the change
should satisfy a log sober living
quality and for now let's take the
conjecture to be modified log so believe
in equality although you could you
cannot pretty cannot be logged so
without any qualifications but so let's
just take it to be sort of say to be
modified and ok I like this question a
lot actually personally told me it had
some even some slightly notorious
history that i will not go into but
basically at least for a little while i
was actually entertained that I mean it
was sort of assumed that this was true I
don't know if it was for like a day or a
week or a month but ok but any case you
can ask if the conjecture has any teeth
like does it does it apply to any
specific chain that you might care about
and honestly my favorite chain in this
context is the globe or dynamics on K
colors of a graph and the reason is
because there you sort of have three
regimes of coupling depending on on the
on the maximum degree so if the maximum
degree is at least four k then sort of a
trivial coupling works and if the
maximum degree sorry if the number of
colors is at least 4 Delta then a triple
a trivial sort of coupling works
if it's at least two builder than jerem
gave us sort of slightly more
interesting coupling that gives you a
contraction and then okay so let me just
end endif if the number of color is 11
six Delta then of then then Eric as sort
of a rather sophisticated coupling of a
blockchain that gives a contraction not
for the not for the global dynamics but
for a different chain but one nice thing
about lots of living equalities is that
if two chains have equivalent their
slave forms then then the log so bless
you get a log so quality for both so
okay so it's not so it's okay that the
contractions for a different chain so
the technique I'll show you works for
for Delta the recent work of Catalan
Martin actually can second sort of
verify lot so when K is at least two
Delta okay and but I really consider
some of the major challenge here to be
sort of getting a lot so believe in
equality below to Delta because that
really requires I mean that seems to
require some substantial advance at
least in my understanding of what's
going on and you can ask if this would
have any applications to say mixing time
so here's i mean i can tell you an
application if you might not be
impressed but for instance the global
dynamics here the gotas method gives a
mixing time n squared log N and if you
establish lots of love you would get too
tight order n log n bound for the
problem but but that's not really the
point of the talk is just that this is a
nice chain to it on which you can test
whether you made progress on the
conjecture okay today I'll tell you but
now about partial progress on the
conjecture that's the that's the point
and for that we need one more object
which is the the transportation distance
this inequality looks imposing mostly
because these these brackets are these
curly braces are so big but it's just
the you know so given two distributions
which here I wrote them as densities
with respect to the stationary measure
the water steam p distance between them
is just you know you want to move the
mass of Wanda tributions the other and
you pay the lp norm of
of the total distance of the mass moved
okay we're only going to look at this
for P equals 1 and P equals two so okay
so also like in the theoretical computer
science community this goes by the name
of the earth mover distance between
distributions and sort of inequalities
relating transportation distances to n
trapeze and relative entropy were
studied by around the same time actually
by Martin and telegram in relation to
concentration of measure phenomena in
various spaces and and they also play a
sort of a central role in the in the
framework of auto and villainy but over
what I want to stress here is a is a
result of Bobkov and goods from 99 which
says that if you admit you're chained
admits a log so believe in equality then
it should also admit aw1 entropy
transport inequality I'll tell you what
explain it in a second we're here we're
you know the metric that we're using to
define sort of transport for transport
were you know metric is the one I told
you on the previous slide that's the the
sort of the induced graph distance
coming from the chain and okay what does
this inequality say well it says that if
if your density f is close to the
stationary measure in in relative
entropy which has nothing to do with
distance it's just an
information-theoretic motion then also
you can move that measure to the
stationary measure without doing too
much work and as the entropy get small I
mean it's a quantitative bump as the
entropy it's smaller than the amount of
work you need to do to move it to the
stationary measure in terms of the
distance is a gets smaller okay so this
is a this is a w1 entropy transport
inequality everybody clear on how it
looks it says that if you're closing one
distance your clothes your closest a
shin area in another distance and by the
way the one here these are density so
this one is really corresponding to the
stationary measure okay so now if you
take the conjecture and you take the and
actually by the way Prasad you I believe
you're a student former student actually
shows that this implication holds even
for modified log so right okay so then
it makes more sense in the slide I'm
saying now so
remind me the name sorry okay so right
so this implication holds even if you
only assume that the chain satisfies a
modified log so believe in equality so
if you take the conjecture and you take
this implication you know it gives you a
possible week conclusion to reach before
you get the main conjecture it's what
i'll tell you about today which is a
joint work with the Ronin and just F if
you have a lower bound on the on the
course Ricci curvature so if you have a
non-trivial contraction in the chain
then you get double you get you get you
get a consequence of the Lok Sabha live
in equality which is that the w1 entropy
transport indeed holds with the Perth
essentially the right constant as Kappa
goes to infinity this is this is 1 over
kappa that's not true but as Kappa goes
to 0 this is 1 over kappa ok all right
so this is what I want to tell you about
and I should say that you know so okay
so I think that what happened is a
Joseph told the max about this result
and and and and the max and the shoe
were already sort of working on entropy
transporting inequalities and they just
observed that their methods can also get
this result we I mean we also have at
least two proofs of this result but the
one I want to present today has the at
least the one positive feature that it's
a it was meant to solve the conjecture
and just get stuck proving this special
you know this consequence of the
conjecture so maybe you can keep pushing
and get all the way there ok good so now
what's the method I when I talk about ok
so now I'll tell you how to prove this
prove this theorem yes
oh yeah well I haven her yes I might
know just know what I just going to
stitch is easier it's it's just the
right it's just the average amount of
mass I mean I just move one measure to
another and i own i pay the sum of the
total distance of everything moved I
just like that so it's so bad you said
that the one in second coordinate if she
does it correspond salvation yeah sorry
sorry here here we're only the
inequality only involves moving some
other measure to the stationary measure
and and the one here is just I was just
saying that just reminding people that
these are densities so the one
corresponds to the stationary measure so
this is you could write mu and pie here
if you want and it would look better
sorry well then you'd have to do
something else over here okay but yes we
we want to show that if the if some if
some density or some distribution has
small relative entropy stationarity and
we can actually move it to stationarity
without paying too much good so now we
prove this theorem using a entropic
interpolation okay so what's the idea of
entropic interpolation so generally you
can think about the setup as you have
some space of paths this script p and
the paths i'll think about as indexed by
time so here i will continue this time
you can also think about the street time
so these are sort of paths in your state
space and then the space of paths comes
equipped with some background measure mu
so for us the background measure is just
going to be I mean the paths again
there's going to be trajectories of a
Markov chain and the measure just going
to be the induced measure coming from
the transition probabilities ok so I'm a
chain you have a bunch of paths you can
talk about the probability that the
random walk takes that path that's going
to be our measure and then there's an
initial measure and a starting measure
Sigma 0 and Sigma T and what we're just
going to look at it is sort of a we're
just going to we want to basically move
Sigma 0 2 Sigma T right this is some
measure this is a mother measure along a
measure of paths right so there's lots
of ways to do it like you can give me
lots of different transport plans for
how to get Sigma 0 2 Sigma T
and what I want to single out the one
which has which has the smallest
relative entropy to the background
measure on paths so that's the
optimization problem I'm considering ok
so this was actually studied in there by
a shredding ER in the 30s in the context
were sort of you take you know suppose a
suppose you have a bunch of gas in two
different configurations you assume that
the way that yes behaves is that the
little gas particles do Brownian motion
that's the background trajectory on the
grip of the background measure on
trajectories and then you look for the
thing like okay if you just do Brownian
motion it's unlikely that you'll end up
in this state Sigma T for instance but
you can ask you know which measures go
which measures on paths go from Sigma 0
2 Sigma T and among those you can you
can think about minimizing the relative
entropy which is the same thing as
maximizing the likelihood so you're
really just asking what's the maximum
likelihood way that this configuration
gets through this configuration in time
T ok but the point is the point of this
entropic interpolation method here is a
to use you know not now you can take
this optimal plan this entropy optimal
plan and you can use properties about it
to to say things about you know your
configurations and I should mention it
for us capital T here is going to be
really large like much larger than a
mixing time of this system and so the
initials the initial distribution is not
so important because it gets lost before
you ever start thinking about getting
close to the final distribution ok so
now let's now let's solve this
interpolation problem in a specific
setting so for just for simplicity of
the talk I'm going to move to discrete
time random walks just because it's
going to be easier for me to tell you
the what the optimal interpolation looks
like the initial measure which I told
you already doesn't isn't going to
matter for us it's just going so we just
started some fixed point x0 so the
initial measure is just the Delta
function or the initial density is a
delta function at some fixed point x0
and the final final measure i want to
write as a density with respect to mu T
where mutti who is the is just the law
of random walk start at x0 so the point
is if you take TV really large muties
is going to be the stationary measure
very close to stationary measure so you
should think about mutti as being the
stationary measure it's just that again
for simplicity and because we're in
discrete time it's nice if you think
about the density as being a density
with respect to the distribution of the
random walk after T steps instead of the
stationary measure okay well so this is
our this is our initial point these are
initial distribution this is our final
distribution and our goal is to describe
now on the slide the the entropy optimal
way to get from the start to the finish
okay and it's not it's not completely
clear because the i mean the the way you
get from the start to the finish is just
by giving a measure on paths so it's not
clear for instance that that the measure
on paths ism is Markovian but it is
Markovian the optimal solution is
Markovian i mean although it is its
timing in homogeneous lee Markovian so
so basically here's the optimal measure
on paths I'm just going to describe it
in terms of a random process that
samples a path from the distribution you
start at X naught the beginning point
and then I just tell you the law for you
know for the where you are at time T
given where you are at time t minus 1
okay and and this will depend on T so
it's a Markov chain but it's not
homogeneous in time and so what you do
is if you're sitting at t minus 1 the
probability you go you transition to Y
is it's just a probability that the the
background Markov chain would do that
just probably that the the chain xt
would make that transition weighted by
okay so weighted by some some factor
where the factor is precisely sort of
basically yeah so this this PT of F is
just sort of the discrete-time heat flow
it's just the you know I start a random
walk from Y of length t minus capital t
minus little t and i see how much f mass
i expect to get at the end point that's
how I wait I wait the point y by by that
quantity and then this is actually just
a normalization factor that makes it a
probability measure some okay I'm just
claiming to you we don't have time to
see it always it's very simple but this
that this is the optimal the entropic
the optimal interpolator
is in the set up I described okay so
it's a it's nice because it's just
Markovian and with a bit longer there's
a picture which would explain it but i
won't i won't tell you let me just tell
you why it's a it's optimal and in fact
this is how you see it's optimal you
write it down and then you just do this
computation so remember what we're
trying to what we're trying to minimize
is actually the relative venture between
our measure on paths which is this one
and the background measure on pass which
is sort of given by this random variable
and it turns out if you define ZT this
way then the the measure you get the
relative entry you get is exactly the
relative entry between the endpoints
right which is I mean this shows that
your that the that the interpolation is
optimal because like there's no way you
can I mean the discrepancy between the
entropy on the measures of the paths has
to be at least a discrepancy between the
measures at the endpoints like you have
to pay at least that much you know
information you know to get to the you
know the XT is going to the stationary
measure and your ZT is going to some
other measure so you have to pay
something just by information processing
inequality like this one has to be at
least this one so the fact you have
equality means that this is the
optimizer and then the fact that your
objective is strictly convex means it's
a unique optimizer but one nice thing
about this is now you can basically
write this this relative entropy you can
use the chain rule okay so this is
essentially what I wrote here and you
can think about the amount of you know
at every step in time naturally I want
to take a step according to the random
walk but I have to end up at some other
measure not the stationary measure at
time capital T so I I perturb the random
luck I do something different and then
you can you can think about the amount
of a sort of relative entropy you spend
as broken down into how much do you
spend at every step so every step you
you spend a certain amount of entropy
which is sort of corresponds to how much
you're going to change the instead of
taking a random walk step you're going
to take a different step this represents
that so this is given that your ads ET
minus 1 this is the measure this is what
Z this is what the z chain would do and
this little p is the transition for the
xchange so this is what the x chain
would do and the chain rule
we this formula okay and now the idea is
now so yeah so now that this is what
your we want to study and I'll just tell
you that in this setup establishing the
modified lock so believe in equality
exactly corresponds to to being able to
say that you know this is the picture
for the information burn okay so the the
information is very sort of your sort of
burning information all the time but it
increases exponentially as you approach
the final time t almost all the
information is burned close to the final
time okay I'll say something more
concrete and less lighter to talk about
but qualitatively this is what it means
to establish modified lok sabha life in
this setting that's a okay but you you
tend not to do a lot of work you tend to
just evolve according to the random walk
until your get close enough to the final
time so close means basically one over
kappa where capital is this curvature
parameter and then when you're close
that's when you start spending all of
your information okay and there's a have
a video to explain why this is the case
I mean it's intuitive anyway but let's
let's just say in words and the reason
is is true is because if you start
spending information early you know you
know then the random walk is going to
erase all this information you spent and
so you're not going to be optimal if you
start spending information too early
right I mean if you if you start trying
to deviate from the random walk over
here but then you don't you're not
willing to spend the whole time to
maintain that deviation then the red the
walk will erase the you know the
deviations you made because it forgets
about where it started at so so you
don't want to spend too much information
until the end that's the picture here's
a video which explains that so what's
going on in the video is a okay so
there's a I'll start the video and then
I'll pause it ok so the video was going
to look like this oh it's supposed to
pause ok so what's going on is this
green stuff is the you know this
particle is actually two particle at the
moment it's red and blue and on top of
each other they make up they make a
purple particle but the blue particle it
has to end in the green set at time zero
and the red particle is just doing
random walk and so that you don't get
too disturbed this is actually a this is
not the best simulation the world this
is actually a torus so you know so we
can go this way to get here okay and if
you look here you'll see how much
pressure the the blue particle is
feeling so as you get you know the blue
particle is doing the optimal
interpolation that we put before so as
we get closer and closer to zero you
know at time zero this thing has to be
in the green set so to see how so the
blue particle is going to be feeling
some pressure yes well then right now
that the same because we're far from the
final time so right now they know they
it feels some pressure but you don't see
it if you look at those numbers you can
see it starts to feel the pressure to
the right now they split so red the red
particles doing random walk I didn't
tell you how they're coupled yet but the
blue particle is doing the this entropy
optimal random walk and you can just see
as we get closer to the final time these
blue particles going to start getting it
to tourists he's going to start getting
pretty desperate to get to the green set
so you see it's sort of like okay it's
getting scared you know it's gonna you
know in a second is like now this is
like an alarm okay so it's a yeah
eventually I mean well mathematically
there it has no choice ok so again
eventually at time zero it lands in the
in the green set okay and the one thing
you can ask here is how I coupled the
red particle so so first of all from the
video you get at least the impression
that night you can sort of see why I
mean you get some intuition about why
the you know why you you're spending
more at the end like you're trying to
deviate more from the random walk at the
end just because I mean it's always
possible at the random walk itself would
end in the green set or it might get
close to the green said you want to wait
around a little while to see if that's
gonna happen before you act okay so
that's the one that you can ask is
what's the coupling I use between the
red and the blue points I use the really
i use a really dumb coupling which was
just a total variation coupling and now
the point is that if you instead of
using a solar variation coupling if you
use the couple and coming from the
contraction then
along this process you you will prove of
entropy transport inequality okay so so
like so so we're okay so just to say
what's going to happen we have the red
thing which is the random walk we have
the blue thing which is the entropy
optimal interpolation we give some
coupling between them you know at some
large time T the red thing is
distributed according to the stationary
measure and the blue thing is
distributed according to F are given
density okay and so if we look at you
know at the end what's the expected
distance between the red particle and
the blue particle that's an upper bound
on the transportation distance between F
and the stationary measure so if we so
we need to give a coupling between the
red and the blue particle and then say
that an expectation they and fairly
close together okay oh we don't want to
see the video again okay so what's the
what's the coupling so suppose we say
that z t minus 1 + xt minus 1 this is
the random walk and this is a this is
the interpolated process that the
optimal interpolation and right this is
the process which at time T should have
the law of F and this one should be
according to the stationary measure so
we assume that we've coupled them so far
and now I want a couple one more step
I'll try to do the most natural thing
here which is first of all okay so z t
minus 1 takes a step and you get ZT so
what we're going to do is we just couple
that step in sort of we take sum total
variation optimal coupling to the actual
random law so we try to make it so that
sort of that step as often as possible I
agrees with what rent with the random
walk would have done from z t minus 1 so
there we just take the total variation
optimal coupling and then but then we're
not trying to this is just coupling ziti
with one step of the random walk we're
trying to a couple ziti with XT and then
we also take a coupling between the xt
walk and the and sort of and this one
step using using the contraption okay so
using so the point is you know here we
we do a step but here we do you think
about doing a step of random walk and
here you do a step of random walk you
couple those two steps you
the assumes contraction and then you
couple this random walk step with ZT
just using the total variation coupling
this is a very natural thing to do and
just by triangle inequality you can
compose couplings in this way so what
happens is just that you know if if in
the total variation coupling ziti and
the one step of the random walk through
different things then you just say okay
fine i paid distance one they split now
they got may be further apart by one but
if they do the same thing then the point
is that now this coupling kicks in
because sort of it when they do the same
thing this step is coupled to the sort
of this step and they tend to contract
so like if they if you if you make a
mistake you pay one if you don't make a
mistake then at least intuitively the
they get closer together an expectation
okay and and what happens you have two
competing factors one is that since you
have this coupling that's encouraging
them to get to get closer together I
rate 1 minus Kappa right like separation
between Z txt it's like a it's it's a
rapidly depreciating asset so sort of if
you achieve some separation then it's
you know it's going to way it's going
away it's an exponential rate because
this contraction is operating there you
know you'd have to if you want to see
keep it from going away then you need to
keep getting differences on the left
hand side which means you need to keep
spending information so this is one
factor so this this makes it so that
you'd like to spend information at the
end because anything you spend know you
can spend information to get a total
variation difference between the law of
ziti and the law of the random walk if
you spend it too early then the
contraction is going to erase it so
you'd like to spend at the end on the
other hand actually if you really care
about getting the chance to make
different decisions over here then you'd
like to spend information as slowly as
possible because actually if you spend
epsilon bits of information you can get
the probability that they make different
choices to be square root of epsilon
because it's been squeezed in equality
is actually you know you cannot improve
it in this regime this is a real thing
so so even with one bit of information
if you're willing to sort of apply it
slowly enough you could
you could get them to make infinitely
many different decisions just because
just because epsilon bits of information
actually gives you square root of
epsilon total variation between the two
measures so there's competing factors
which is that if you if you spend
information slowly then it's cheaper for
you but the decay is encouraging you to
spend information at the end because
it's erasing the progress you made okay
all right so the proof is just you Yuko
she sports 1 and two together and then
even I get the bell so that's the I mean
I'm not going to write down the formula
but that's that's basically what you do
you take these two competing factors and
koji Schwartz tells you the worst case
for this so there's something coming
from the decay and there's some there's
some factor essentially coming from from
Pinsky's inequality which tells you that
you know given the amount of information
you're going to spend the whole time you
know you can't get the you can't always
be forcing the chain to make different
decisions in the random walk would've
made is it is the intuition of that
clear one out of 99 or I don't have any
people are here the one out of 100 no
that's not that's not that yeah
sorry that this is the relative entropy
between it so basically what I'm saying
is certify the total amount of
information you have to spend is the is
the entropy of F so if we have a process
which is entropy optimal so we know that
sort of the yeah it's sort of it ok so
it's buried here we know that is the sum
of the the sum of the relative entropy
is between our law and the random walk
law over time is going to be equal to
the is going to be equal to the relative
entropy of the density F with respect to
the stationary measure so that's sort of
and you know and and if we wait and we
can by sort of spending that at various
times we can get the two processes to
make different decisions yeah so this is
just saying yeah this is just sort of
this is just for two general measures
mule and new you have this inequality
and in fact it's a you know like the
square root is a real thing so if you
spend information more slowly you can in
fact do much better on total variation
separation okay so that's the proof so
now the last slide just go back to the
sort of what does the modify what we've
modified log so we'll have look like in
this setting well it's a it's exactly
what I said before which is just that
you want to show that the the if you
look at the information spent per at
every time then you want to say that it
is actually increasing exponentially
near the end of the process so strictly
is being all you need is that in the
last order 1 / kappa steps you see a
constant fraction of the total
information spent ok and again the sort
of the hopefully sort of you see why the
contraction should be encouraging this
since since you're paying an exponential
decay factor it's pretty it's ok it
seems intuitive that in fact that you
would want to only spend information
near the end and actually in an
exponential fashion so like intuitively
this suggests the case unfortunately
intuition is not always sufficient we're
getting a proof so here are two
questions well one is actually I don't
even know this curve is monotone in
various cases you can you can you can
verify that it's monotone
I think it's a fascinating question
whether it's actually monotone if you
say start instead of from a fixed point
start from the stationary measure and
take T going to infinity is it the case
that is sort of the on average the
amount of information you're spending is
increasing with time she'd be true I
don't know how to prove it except in
some special cases it's also not
necessary in order to prove the
conjecture because you know this is sort
of a course bound but right like you
would expect that this this question is
a positive answer because if you're at a
certain point and you're like wow I'm
about to spend you know I'm about to do
a lot of effort to get my process to
differ from the random walk but I look
out in the future and I'm not spending
so much so why wouldn't I just slow down
a little bit and be patient and wait
before I make this move it seems like a
proof right okay it's not quite all
right anyway so it's a ancient
fascinating question and then what's the
what's the point of this what's the
strata strategy for the for modified log
soap well improving sort of the entropy
transporting the quality we didn't use
the fact that we didn't really use
optimality of the process very closely
we use we only use that sort of say it
it uses that most a certain amount of
information the whole time but when you
really talk about optimality you can use
you know you can use convex duality and
this turns out to be very powerful at
least in some other settings so sort of
in the galaxy and setting it was used
strongly by Burrell and with Ronan last
year we used it to prove sort of to
answer all the conjecture of telegrams
about the orange team loom back but the
idea is basically that if your if your
process is not following this curve if
you look out into the future and you see
that you're not going to be spending a
lot more information in the future then
you know you would you would like to
give some some witness like you know you
sort of sale I could be doing something
better okay and I and if you look at a
duality formula right like this you have
a lot of freedom and how you can say
you're doing better right you don't have
to give a Markovian that you can just
you know just give a different law and
paths and
you know which indicates that you're not
doing doing things optimally okay it
seems okay it's believable that this
could work so that's the that's the main
open question whether you can establish
this pursuit holly conjecture in
particularly be nice if you do it using
entropic interpolation so that's the end
of the talk let me just before for no
reason other than the fact that I can
make these videos with just with one
line now I'll just show you one
interpolation from state the stationary
measure on a torus this is like a
entropy optimal interpolation to
something okay I don't know we don't
need to wait for it he's not a loop
though actually the only point is that
it's that I just want to you know that i
made this video specifically for you so
it's actually labeled by the 2016 okay
so that's that's then thanks
there any questions so I'm wondering
what about the implications for coloring
using your proof I mean you need a
coupling to be the second coupling as a
so if you want to use this entropy
interpolation approach then the K being
for delta coupling allows you to just
use to basically you know when you want
to say that the process that they that
if the if the process was not spending
information in this according to this
exponential curve then you want to say
it's not optimal and using the simple
coupling you can do that just by looking
at the current step in the next step
right so it's very so it's very simple
when you get to to Delta it seems that
that you need the sort of the you have
to look further than a constant distance
into the future and it just looked
really good just looks complicated
Martin manages to establish it and by
the way she establishes the real log
sold not modified lemon sorry its
diminutive to modify the locks of the
non-modified log so believe in equality
but hers is using a is using a method
inspired by the transportation machinery
although not it's a it's a it's
fascinating yeah so so that's Nate's
using like very different from this but
also using very strongly this at least
the structure of the fact that sort of
the chain is a gibbs sampler so it
doesn't it doesn't go it doesn't work
for below to delta when that when we
don't know of a contraction for the
gibbs sampler you said going to stop
dating one for texts yeah sorry
but as I've but in the case when we have
say Eric's coupling for block dynamic
can you use your machinery or her
machinery with what to be to get I think
you came you came late that was
described in a slide answers the answer
is that's that that's the challenge I
think just for a specific chain that's
the concrete problem where we don't know
how to get logs to live in her setting
it doesn't fit you have to modify it
because it's but here and you know here
at least you can phrase it in this
setting but I don't how to do it what do
I fight or what if I have a chain where
is it is to give sampler but I'm not
doing though the simple path metric
works like and Kristen Santa and I
showed attraction of some other metric
that does it I mean so this is a this is
a great question Martin's technique will
not apply basically what you're saying
is I don't your what your I believe
you're intending a metric that's
equivalent to the path metric but the
point is you're saying that contraction
might not kicking in one step it might
take thousand steps
number of our transition right but like
but likely its equivalent like within a
factor of 10,000 upper and lower bound
within the width of the path metric even
then it's it's it's not clear because I
think what you're describing is
something where if you consider the path
metric then you would have a contraction
it's just that you wouldn't get it
stepwise it rates a coarser contraction
that on average you know in the future
contracts things together but you don't
see it in one step I think I think what
you're describing is a contraction for a
different metric which you can also
think about as a contraction for the
original metric it doesn't kick in right
away if there's a comparison between the
two metrics showing that the transport
entropy nice quality follows wearing w1
you put the new distance the entropy
transport proof would still work but but
those continuous-time techniques I mean
what really what they take advantage of
is that I mean continuous space
techniques is that is that the curvature
is in some sense kicking in
instantaneously and and somehow the
problem with the screen change is that
at least you have to at least wait one
before you make one step before you see
it and you're describing I think
essentially the same problem which is
that you know if you if you have a
Hugh's a different metric you might have
to wait a longer amount of time before
you see the contraction it should work
but I don't know how to do it but it
does work for the entropy transporting a
quality yeah
I had a question so the conjecture says
that if you have this curvature you
should have exponential decay of entropy
it's a bit different than that because
it's going it's it's exponential
increase of information and it's not
treat ETA is exponential together yes
okay sorry yeah sorry you would you
expect that if you have curvature you
also have a convex decay of entropy make
attempts to prove it much more I mean
battery Emery principle is based on
convex decay of entropy these are
fantastic questions the best audience
ever had so I ok but Creamery is based
on two things it's based on convex decay
of entropy but it's actually but it's
based on a strong point wise complex
decay of entropy in fact their method
even gives local logs tabla of
inequalities it doesn't depend on the
invariant measure so point wise you will
even if you have in the discrete setting
you will not get something nice like
this but you could ask if you have
convexity on average with respect to the
stationary measure and that is
essentially this question and I don't
even know it in the case of a diffusion
on a manifold so in fact this is it is
this question because when your average
under the stationary measure you exactly
get the question of whether the
derivative of the Fisher information
under the heat flow is negative and I
and for some reason that note that
question seems to be open like okay